We hear collagen is to our bones.
It's like mortar is to bricks.
Can collagen repair a large cavity?
What about missing tooth adenous?
So I think cavity, you're talking about cavity in your teeth.
No, no, no, it's not gonna repair a large cavity.
There's a lot of different type of toothpaste
that uses data-ized, hydroxyapotite microcrystalline,
hydroxyapotite, which is the type of calcium
that goes into the tooth and into the bone.
I actually use that toothpaste
because my sinus condition,
I have to breathe through my nose at night and my teeth are out
and I'm very prone to cavities.
So since I started using the data-ized micro-micronized
hydroxyapotite type toothpaste,
I think you can get it on a,
I get it on just an Amazon,
I can't remember the brand,
no, maybe you think of it before I've done with this call.
But there's other brands, there's other brands,
two that use data-ized hydroxyapotite
in the toothpaste, that might be your best bet.
Collegiate is gonna be really good
for your connective tissue.
Collegiate really isn't gonna build your bones,
and maybe that's the metaphor here.
Mortar is to bricks, mortar holds the bricks together.
Your collagen is gonna help your connective tissue
that holds the bones together.
Collegiate is gonna build both.